on va passer à nos amis au gilet jaune
un coup médiatique réussie oui ou non
sachez qu hier je suis sorti voilà du
studio il y avait des gilet jaune qui
m'attendait et qui m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient un coup de gueule à faire dans
une émission et m'ont demandé si je
voulais bien leur donner la parole j'ai
dit moi la parole ici elle est ouverte à
tout le monde
donc ils vont nous en parler dans un
instant regardez les arrière-gardes et
s'étire déjà petite vidéo récap des
filets jaunes ces parties de vidéos les
gilet jaune c'est le sujet du moment
quatrième jour de mobilisation des
jeunes est jaune gilles et jean gilet
jaune en gilet jaune sur internet le
phénomène est aussi présent partout en
moins de 48 heures c'est plus d'un
million de messages avec le hashtag
gilet jaune qui ont été publiés en ligne
dans les rues les médias parlent de 280
2000 français mobilisés pour crier leur
colère contre le gouvernement une colère
également dirigés à l'encontre des
journalistes qui ont fait les frais de
plusieurs agressions à de nombreuses
reprises des biens
une agression symboliquement forte est
pas isolé plusieurs autres journalistes
ont dû faire les frais ce week-end de ce
type de comportement hostile que ce soit
pour leur mobilisation massive ou les
indécents inhérents à ces rassemblements
une chose est sûre les gilets jaunes ont
réussi à faire parler d'eux une partie
du pays a décidé de continuer le
mouvement une poursuite qui n'est pas de
l'avis de tout le monde
à l'image de christophe castaner le
ministre de l'intérieur aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'on a une dérive totale
mais entre polémiques et message
politique à votre avis les gilets jaunes
ont ils réussi leur coup médiatique
alors justement on a avec nous bonjour
on a il dit il dira qu'elle a braqué
derrière que j'ai vu hier soir qu'il est
informaticien on à adele qui est
superviseur ferroviaire qui s'est blessé
et qui est là quand même ce soir et qui
est avec nous on à jean claude qui est
vtc voilà qui était avec nous qu'ils
étaient hier qu'ils étaient hier aussi
avec moi dans la rue et maxi vous êtes
intérimaire vous avez travaillé dans la
logistique dans les transports et dans
la mécanique alors moi les cherry on est
en direct ici on m'avait dit nous on
voit là on en a marre et on a un coup de
gueule à passer parce que a priori vous
trouvez que vous avez un traitement
médiatique qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
conforme à ce que vous attendiez bas on
a un traitement médiatique qui fait qui
montre complètement l'averse de ce qui
se passe sur le terrain
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce qui vous
dérange dans ce qui est dit dans les
médias ce qui nous dérange c'est qu'on
met une différence encore une fois on
divise les gens ont divisé entre le
mauvais gilet jaune et le gentil si toi
qu'est ce que c'est que le mauvais gilet
jaune balle mauvais gilet jaune c'est
celui qui va par exemple [ __ ] un gilet
jaune parce que c'est facile d'en mettre
un et puis aller casser une voiture
parce qu'il a cru que c'était
c'était une soirée festival donc voilà
c'est le bon gilet jaune
le bond gilet jaune y en a partout ici
qui ne manque pas d'ailleurs vrai que
c'est tous ceux qui en ont marre de
payer trop cher je vois plein de gens
qui font comme ça et pourtant ils ont
pas de jouer
vous ce que vous dites c'est que vous
reprochez aussi aux gens de dire que
vous avez été 270000 aux médias dire que
vous avez été 2 centimes il s'auto 170
me le samedi alors vous étiez beaucoup
plus et ça on était largement plus où
vous étiez combien pour vous franchement
entre 2 et 3 millions trop tôt et 3
millions est tout le temps sur le calcul
le calcul est simple les médias ont dit
lui même il y avait à peu près de 1000
points de rassemblements en france
mais depuis le point de rassemblement
sur 280 mille personnes ça fait à peu
près une moyenne de 100 personnes par
rassemblement les médias nous montrent
eux mêmes est beaucoup plus que 100
personnes par rassemblement donc ça
prouve déjà un clavier veut calcul alors
pourquoi pourquoi vous pensez que les
médias parce que voilà nous on fait
partie aussi
voilà essayé de minimiser la chaux
minimiser les choses et aussi de
d'essayer de dire que voilà votre coup
médiatique n'est pas réussi parce que si
vous voulez faire c'est faire bouger les
choses qu'on parle de vous pour que ça
puisse bouger derrière au niveau du
gouvernement
c'est ça aussi mais c'est pas vraiment
un coup médiatique on n'essayait pas de
venir mais c'est important aussi que
plus on en parle plus les jeunes à
bouger derrière il ya énormément de
choses qui circulent sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont censurés énormément
c'est vrai que je rends toi moi par
exemple la barque depuis deux heures
j'ai plus du tout accès au live fait pu
commenter les choses et j'en envoie des
messages qui sont censurés je peux pas
envoyer de messages vocaux ya des
comptes qui sont fermées avec des
messages qui disent par exemple pour un
contenu inapproprié votre compte a été
suspendu pendant deux jours et c est ce
que vous comprenez voilà la question que
vous vous posez
voilà où nous moi je voulais dire moi je
comprends tout à fait qu'ils aient des
gens qui veulent qu'ils veulent
revendiquer le fait de vivre mieux et de
pouvoir se sentir mieux dans une autre
société nécessité voilà c'est ça
maintenant il ya forcément des gens
aussi qui sont avec vous qui peuvent pas
sortir dans la rue qui ont peur qu'ils
ont peur des débordements et quand vous
dit tout à l'heure il ya des mauvais
gilet jaune est ce que vous pouvez
comprendre aussi que le gouvernement
dans leur tête et surtout au niveau de
la sécurité se disent nous on peut pas
distinguer les mauvais gilet jaune des
bons gilet jaune et ça peut être
compliqué pour nous voilà d'aider des
rassemblements de masse comme ça est-ce
que vous pouvez le comprendre où est ce
que voyant ces cas là dans ces cas là on
accepte on accepte de mettre en place
des autorisations sur le territoire qui
permettent de sécuriser les lieux à voir
aujourd'hui 0 autorisation préfectorale
est ce que aujourd'hui 0 et je le tiens
des renseignements territoriaux avec qui
je suis en contact il ya eu zéro
autorisation de valider sur le
territoire est ce qu'aujourd'hui en
nommant ne valident aucune autorisation
et il sait qu'il va y avoir des
déplacements de masse il met en danger
les gens d'accord donc vous comprenez
aussi
voilà qui est qui et des gens et que les
gens qui aient peur de tous ses
mouvements il ya eu quand même y aller
aujourd'hui on a eu le moment blessé
voilà tous les mouvements de foule tous
les mouvements comme ça ça cesse a fait
ça fait peur ça a gagné accident vous
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça est-ce
que vous vous sentez vous êtes entendus
ou pas du tout pour l'instant oui on a
entendu un minimum mais pas assez pas
sûr que là pour l'instant il ya trois
semaines les goûts fin le gouvernement
ne faisait aucune allocution là dessus
on ne parlait pas là c'est de plus en
plus forte que ça va que je mens ça mais
ça bouge concrètement puisque on a des
fins g on a des documents on a des
choses qui remonte du terrain là
aujourd'hui sur le territoire
personne ne sait vraiment ce qui se
passe puisque c'est difficile de
centraliser quand on a pas
d'organisation mais par contre eh ben on
en a quand même une moitié d'une puisque
des gens s'occupent tous les jours comme
eric doré par exemple de faire remonter
les informations des gens direction
grâce à éric qui fait un travail
exceptionnel
si le rappeler parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de joie c'est lui qu'il faut voilà qui
travaillent avec vous et voilà que
laisser faire exception et qui fait du
beau boulot moi moi la question que j'ai
à vous poser est ce que vous pensez pas
aussi que mine de rien le fait qu'ils
aient des débordements ça pollue un peu
le débat ça pollue un peu le message et
ça fait qu'aujourd'hui comme vous dites
les mauvais gilet jaune vous font du
tort et qu'aujourd'hui ça fait que les
choses avancent mois bien au niveau du
gouvernement
oui oui alors on se tutoie parce qu'on
se connaît depuis en sai on est potes il
a dormi à la maison tutti quanti un
gilet jaune pyjama jaune tout ce que
tout ça alors vas-y mon désir alors
enfin passant chez son micro on est en
rupture de stock merci vas-y dire voilà
en fait par rapport à ça râle bien for
money dire par rapport à ça ce que je
voulais dire c'est que quand nous on
arrive sur des points de manifestation
ça se passe très bien enfin moi pour
lesquelles j'ai assisté en tout cas ça
se passait très bien le problème
il est où c'est que lorsque vous avez
les policiers les crs
bon nous on n'en veut pas aux policiers
aux crs on y travaille on leur donne des
ordres là où ils veulent
li veulent pas que la cause avance ils
commencent à rentrer dedans à gaz et à
mettre des lacrymo il ya un moment donné
ça excite tout le monde alors que on
arrive on est on est pacifique ya aucun
problème vous n'êtes pas si vous voulez
que les choses avancent comme aurait dit
voilà moi ce soir je vous ai laissé la
parole aux élus du msp a créé de la
tension en fait c'est ça c'est ça qui
crée elle a créé de la tension ça se
passe mais derrière le message le
message il est brouillé derrière les
choses avancent moins bien et nous ce
qu'on voudrait pour vous je vous le dis
c'est pour ça que je vous fais parler ce
soir c'est que le message avant ce que
le gouvernement prenne des décisions
vous le voyez il vous entendre de plus
en plus ils essaient de vous écouter
c'est de faire avancer les choses
donc plus vous allez avoir des tribunes
comme ça vous allez pouvoir vous
expliquez vous exprimer
calmement et de dire les choses plus à
mon avis les choses vont avancer pour
vous et nous ce qu'on veut
joli et moi ce que je veux en premier
quand vous êtes venu me voir hier c'est
si demain je peux être votre porte
parole enfin voilà à l'attelé et si vous
voulez venir me voir
chaque fois que vous avez un message est
qu'on puisse faire avancer les choses
dans le calme et fr que voilà les choses
vont avancer pour les français que vous
défendez pas ce que vous défendez la
cause de tous les français en sortant
dans la rue il y en a plein voilà si ça
c'est pas sorcier
mais voilà et que derrière ça peut aider
à sortir métier on fera avec plaisir
parce que nous on a on a envie que d'une
chose c'est que tout le monde se sente
bien dans cette société
et voilà et je sais que vous j'en ai
j'ai parlé avec plein d'entre vous y est
et vous sentez mal vous êtes dans un
mal-être et forcément ça crée des
tensions et ensuite voilà c'est celle
escalade voilà aujourd'hui on a vu voilà
qui a eu des débordements
nous ce qu'on voudrait que ce soit mais
que dans le calme on arrive à faire
avancer les choses on a on à mon ami vtc
jean-claude qu'elle relève toi bonjour
claude que tu es magnifique
vas-y ah oui merci cyril déjà nous
accorder quand même là en fait de nous
donner la parole quant au voile alors le
gouvernement
moi je dirais monsieur castaner c'est un
menteur nous nous avons posé un préavis
pour samedi on était quai de bercy on
est allé à la bastille la préfecture n'a
pas respecté ce que ce qu'on avait au
préalable mis sur sur le pré et enfin
sur le pré ali ils nous ont chargés dès
6h du matin
alors que voilà on était pacifique on
avait un préavis on était dans les
règles au niveau des vtc de gilet jaune
et jean-claude je prends pas moi je
prend la défense de personnes nine et
voilà je vous savez que voilà moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est que vous soyez vous
comprenez aussi qu'il ya des français
quoi qu'ils disent nous on a peur de ces
mouvements de foule donc forcément les
policiers sont sous tension aussi il est
crs et tout le monde est sous tension
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que voilà
c'est que les choses avancent pour vous
quels sont les prochains mouvements qui
vont arriver là dans l'est dans les
prochaines heures et dans les prochains
jours toute la semaine les points
important sur le pv seront bloqués
d'accord les raffineries les plates
formes logistiques et
les raffineries les aéroports les qu'est
ce que vous dites aux français parce
qu'il ya plein de français aussi qui
travaillent ce que je dis c'est que
c'est que c'est simple en fait quand on
quand on se bat les uns envers les
autres ça n'avance pas ouais d'accord
donc quand on bloque 1 1 par exemple une
raffinerie au bout d'un moment puis
d'essence dans les véhicules du coup ça
fait chier les gens bien sûr il ya plein
de gens savent aller travailler
aujourd'hui au moment où pendant 30 ans
les gens n'arrivent plus à vivre quand
il ya des gens qui meurent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez d'argent parce qu'ils
ont un à un ils craquent
psychologiquement parce qu'ils ont
passés de salaire je parle aussi des
forces de l'ordre parce que je voudrais
leur passer un message ce soir sur par
exemple pour l'insécurité tous les
points de blocage qui font partie de ma
ville les forces de l'ordre on leur a
permis d interpellation quand il y avait
des personnes qui avaient des
comportements agressifs alcoolisées ou
qu'ils souhaitaient cas c'est ce que
c'est pas le but
bien sûr des actions ils ont interdit
sont intervenus correctement ils ont bu
le café avec nous ils discutent et c'est
au nord de bordeaux par exemple les crs
ont posé leur casque parce que les
sirènes les manifestants les ont
encerclés pacifiquement ils ont dit
qu'ils étaient passés en nombre ils ont
posé leurs casques ils ont discuté avec
les manifestants les manifestants ont
dit crs avec nous mais ce sont des
vidéos que vous ne verrez pas
puisqu'elles ont été censurés presque
une heure après pourquoi parce que c'est
difficile de voir un crs position
derrière je vous ai vu ça ils sont sûrs
et c'est difficile d'expliquer par qui
parce qu'il faudrait savoir d'où ça
vient mais à l'encontre des preuves
parmi les lignes 2 heures et puis parce
qu'il ya un uniforme dans ce coup là
vidéo disparaît je peux vous l'expliqué
simplement il ya des algorithmes que
facebook a clairement mis fin aux jours
de tout le monde il ya des algorithmes
qui permettent de reconnaître un visage
d'un uniforme
il suffit simplement dans l'algorithme
de rentrer contient uniforme on efface
où le contenu est approprié à leur guise
s'il vous plaît justement position de
tête théoriquement dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions il n'a pas le napa loi va
pas on va pas rentrer là dedans mais
vrai que vous nous disiez juste les gens
locales et fuselées donc sais pas quelle
est la chose que vous reprochez aux
médias actuellement parce que je vous ai
senti très énervé pourquoi parce que les
gilet jaune s'est traité par tous on le
voit les chaînes d'info fait d'accord
c'est cette phrase là les gilet jaune
c'est quoi alors qu'est ce qui vous gêne
mais ce qui me gêne c'est que les
je ne sais j'y joue sans cesse et la
france c'est ça c'est juste la cave est
sorti seul et gilet jaune en disant ça
va être un moyen visuels de voir les
gens c'est ça qui est qu'il ya une
grogne
le problème c'est qu'un délit s'il ya
des gens qui sont énervés ils en ont pas
ouais donc c'est pas des mauvais vous
parlez alors vous assure qu'on vous nous
sommes parce que c'est plus facile quand
on nomme quelqu'un de faire les
différences et moi ce que ce que ce que
je pense est ce que beaucoup pensent
comme eric drew et comme mes amis qui
sont là par exemple pas aujourd'hui je
suis monté il ya seulement où le billet
de train qui a été payé par par la
chaîne que je peux je rembourserai mais
si on tour est ce assez le billet de
train payer salaires
gaia le patron l'a fait quand on l'a
pris à m on vous a payé un billet très
novateur mais bon si ce sera remboursé
non mais vous êtes fou quoi non je suis
pas fou non mais non mais c'est normal
c'est normal on vous fait déplacer c'est
normal j'ai besoin de venir voir quelque
chose c'est pas j'ai pas besoin de
combat non mais je vous dis non mais ça
c'est là on va pas faire seul centre
tout ça pour dire que la seule chose que
ça fait donc il ya toujours des en marge
de ce genre de mouvement toujours des
casseurs d'édition d'aider des gens qui
sont casse noix forcément mais ça a
rassemblé énormément de personnes qui le
français break et je peux vous dire que
pour avoir été sur des blocages par
exemple samedi de 8 heures du matin
jusqu'à 20 heures
il ya une solidarité qui est
exceptionnel que je veux vous dire pour
pour finir je vous dire moi je pense que
tous les français qui nous regardent ils
ont envie que ça avance ils ont envie
que les choses changent
mine de rien ils sont derrière vous même
ceux qui viennent pas avec les médias le
seul le seul truc
le seul truc c'est que ici peut-être non
mais non monsieur les médias on sait pas
écouter on va voir il ya des médias qui
sont en tout cas ils sont pas contre
vous les médias à la presse voilà moi je
pense que nous en tout cas ici sur l'ale
sur les chaînes du groupe canal+
on n'est pas on est on est on est on est
ronde avec vous après les autres chaînes
je ne sais pas et je pense qu'ils sont
ils sont avec moi aussi maintenant le
seul truc c'est qu'on voudrait que ça
avance pour vous je vous dis on aimerait
et je pense que tous les français sont
arrivés vous et si vous arrivez à faire
bouger les choses vous enseignent déjà
exposé des toiles abbas et c'est déjà
exceptionnel ce que vous avez fait juste
les chéris fait le juste finir une par
une chose il ya des gens qui me
regardent avec des yeux là les les
fleurs jaunes or les consignes qui ont
été données c'est de ne plus bloquer les
gens waits et ce à partir le moment de
façon les gens n'ont plus d'essence
puisque les raffineries sont bloquées et
je vous garantis qu'il a vu les
documents contenant nos positions ça va
pas tarder les aéroports sont bloqués
marignane par exemple il reste deux
jours et demi d'autonomie les cuves sont
vides
donc ça va pas tarder non plus mais vous
savez que benjamin castaldi d'aller voir
sa femme une de ces femmes l'aéroport de
marignane
rapide donc donc oui mais ça pour dire
que les revendications elles sont
simples on veut ça peut paraître bizarre
pour certains ce qu'on demande mais
c'est la destitution du président
puisque il ya deux présidents à la
renverse la rue de l'elysée pour tous de
se trouver un nouveau job
non mais non interdire de boîtes les
riches là là là je voulais dans la
france où il ya les l'humain ça qu'elle
est l'humain dans la politique
d'aujourd'hui l'a complètement disparu
non mais alors je vous aime je vous aime
beaucoup maxime mais là et je vous dis
je vous donne un conseil là dessus vous
pouvez pas ça c'est un truc qui va de
décrédibiliser le mouvement non parce
qu'il ya ces structures est derrière mme
c'est pas juste c'est bien sûr la
définition de la démocratie mais dites
moi alors démocratie c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
pour le peuple
il fait pas donc il fait pas son boulot
donc bon nous on estime nous le peuple
estime eau qui fait pas son boulot
ils ont qu'à partir de ce moment là s'il
est pas capable de faire son boulot donc
pas capable selon ses pas seulement
c'est selon les français 45 millions
d'électeurs selon les personnes qui
n'arrivent pas à finir leurs fins de
mois et qui finissent bien maxime max
max et c'est maxime maxime et adel moi
je vous dis c'est pour moi je pense que
il on ne croyez moi je pense vraiment
qu'ils ont envie de faire bouger les
choses
ils ont envie de discuter avec vous je
suis sûr que vous allez faire bouger les
choses et vous allez faire c'est
renoncer parce qu'il montre non mais à
présent au moment du mépris puisque
autre chose quand on écoute quand on
écoute edward physique sur france 2 je
suis dimanche soir après si c'est pas du
mépris qu'il a pour nous raymond très
vite non mais moi j'adore j'ai aimé le
mouvement des gilet jaune parce que ces
gens qui sont cons été manifesté pour la
première fois après très vite ça va être
compliqué de faire très vite
c'est un ras-le-bol les sens c'est la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder ya eu
des liens 80 sur les routes et les
retraités moi j'ai eu beaucoup de peine
de voir les retraités aller dans la rue
personne les a aidés ils ont été tout
seuls et ils ont pas été entendu
maintenant ce que votre mouvement je
suis avec vous à 200% moi j'ai pris 500
euros par an d'augmentation avec le
gasoil qui va peut-être baissé montech
les bars et l'on sait pas là où je me
suis passé quand vous dites on va
bloquer les raffineries et on va bloquer
comme les on a vu les carrefours les
leclerc centres commerciaux
quand vous faites ça il ya des gens qui
travaillent et quand ils travaillent pas
parce que vous bloquer le centre
commercial et touchent pas leurs primes
etc etc
bien sûr ils ont dit
ce raté récemment alors bloqué sur la
route par un chauffeur livreur comment
il va fermer 6 et eddy simon bloqués sur
la route je reste un quart d'heure j'ai
parlé avec eux je suis avec vous moi je
préférerais plutôt que vous faites des
demandes sas ya des demandes en
préfecture et que fera sans secousse dît
un endroit bien précis qui seront bas
c'est ça qu'il faut dénoncer caunes a
parlé d' reste il regarde et qui sont
entre eux n'attendaient pas finir sans
vous battre pour les autorisations
trouver des lieux ton cornes champs
elysées peu importe d'élus au symbolique
sur paris où on se rassembleraient
pousse en avant de laisser le monde mais
un barrage avec dit merci au delà un
barrage avec géo personnes la salle max
et bloquer les raffineries
maxime est alors juste pour pau pour
finir et pour clôturer
sachez que voilà nous on a on a envie
que ça bouge pour vous on a envie que ça
bouge pour les français mais je pense
qu'il faut des demandes qu'ils soient
qui qui mena blé sucre est raisonnable
parce que si l'on est descendu ce qui
est donc voilà c'est dur devancé les
demandes l'aîné avec la législation du
mort via une liste de demandes qui est
en train d'être écrite qui sera proposé
samedi une accorte avec les rideaux et
tout à l'heure et les personnes qui sont
sur ceux qui sont avec lui à préparer ça
il y aura une liste de revendications
on espère être reçue par délégation sur
les champs-elysées pas samedi après-midi
par quelques indicateurs faut discuter
on n'est pas des sauvages ça on est des
êtres humains mais en attendant il faut
que ce soit on continue parce que depuis
30 ou 40 ans les gens ont tout essayé
manifestation là je suis un métier pas
réussi un métier par là les
intermittents du spectacle qui sont tous
derrière à travailler et chacun son
métier tout le monde a essayé un peu à
droite que moi jusqu'au bout et c'est
difficile de se réécouter parce que
quand on est petit on pèse pas en face
d'un gouvernement qui avait pas ce
qu'ils veulent bosser aussi
ouais mais si on fait rien est-ce que
vous avez vu le sert et les futures
augmentations de taxes que vous paierez
on comprendrait qu'il ya plein de gens
aussi qui nous regardent qui nous disent
on peut on peut pas aller bosser et ça
aussi vous les comprenez mine de rien
est ce que vous croyez encore chez nous
par exemple les véhicules passent on
bloque les cas mieux c'est vrai mais bon
s'il a plus d'essence derrière ça va
être compliqué un chauffeur-livreur tout
ça c'est parce que ça va bloquer le pays
est ce que vous croyez encore au
gouvernement
absolument pas mais c'est c
qui est capable de croire que quelqu'un
politique met en application quelque
chose à partir du moment que c'est pas
rentable
moi je suis moi je suis persuadé qu'ils
vont finir sait très bien qu'il est que
là la bonne solution
ce serait la discussion se serait
d'avancé sur avec eux et je suis
persuadé de sa vie on leur proposera un
mystérieux et moi je voir les solutions
pour que sais je souhaite que tous dans
le monde sans issue parce que on parle
d'écologie de seconde par exemple quand
on voit les propositions du gouvernement
qui dit on va pour les familles les plus
pauvres faire changer de véhicule volé
qui polluent pour un véhicule électrique
pollue quatre fois plus qu'un véhicule
c'est pour l'écologie ont fait augmenter
le prix du carburant ne l'ont taxé par
des avions des bateaux c'est pour
l'écologie non mais c'est super c'est
tout le monde ici sur ce plateau en vous
avez tous des moyens différents
mais ça on est d'accord sur 4 5 ans à la
sensation cinquante mille bornes à
l'essai alors il dit aujourd'hui vous
êtes quelque part aussi en gilet jaune
mais je vous ai changé pas le contraire
moi je dis le contraire ne pas empêcher
les gens il ya eu certes aussi d'aller
bien sûr mais c'est les quolibets les
gens se voir ma journée il ya des gens
qui perdent leur jeu ils ont évidemment
les 60 heures par jour c'est circuler
les informations donc les informations
là on a la chance y'a t'il fait beaucoup
d'audimat et ça pour ça qu'on a vu ici
c'est pour faire comprendre aux gens
qu'il ne faut pas bloquer les voitures
peser sur l'économie mais bloquer les
loyers les gens voient l'or alors
d'essence de maxime s'est transmis mais
avant de faire des rassemblements bien
d'abord avant de peut avant de menacer
ça fait déjà bien rassemblement
juste pour dire à raymond c'est pas
rationnel c'est l'exaspération des gens
à 1175 euros nets le smic ce n'est tu
peux pas dire donc les enfants exaspérés
et la voix de la raison peut-être mais
elle est inaudible en ce moment moi je
vous suis moi je suis sûr que samedi et
j'espère que vous allez trouver une
solution mais on les a dit devant des
fois on espère aussi voilà le côté
rationnel prendra le pas sur le côté
nous ne changerons pas de cap
non mais ça risque de dépasser sera
versé dès et je viserai su persuader
qu'il ne demande qu'une chose c'est
discuter avec vous et si on devait faire
avancer les choses vous verrez je suis
persuadé que ça va avancer et vous
reviendrez nous le dira bien entendu
quand vous mourrez mais je vous dis je
suis sûr que ça va avancer et je suis
persuadé qu'on va trouver une issue et
que grâce à vous j'espère plein de
français vont pouvoir vivre non c est je
vous le dis on mangeait des infos ça va
je vous dis je sais que là que je sais
que le gouvernement travaill voilà dans
votre sens essayé essayé voilà de
travail va avoir un dialogue parce qu'on
lui laissera pas le choix de travailler
dans le sens du poil mais justement ça
c'est ça c'est pas bon ça allait
descendre les gars non non non mon
peuple je verse aux records on a en un
an
moi je bosse dans le ferroviaire donc la
réforme des retraites mairies de du
ferroviaire plus a maintenant un an
juste en un an
je tends jeu tend l'autre joue
maintenant je sais il faut être crédible
le plus primé des personnes qui
réussissent
moi par exemple je réussis à pas trop en
allemagne vers l'est mais on dit pour
rester rationnel comment voulez vous
qu'une personne qui commence un mois
avec un salaire qui tombe et qui voit
son compte en banque est moins 200 euros
mais soit rationnelle la colère aller là
et je connais je veux dire ni des gens
abandonner quand on peut plus remplir le
frigo et au regard de ses enfants dans
les yeux on fait comment idir du
gouvernement vont rester rationnel où
l'on se bat et on sort dans la rue mais
tous sont nés dire qu'on parle d'une
chose aussi ce soir pour ça que je sais
ça car partant ça va être vite moi
j'aimerais quand même qu'on ait une
pensée pour cette dame qui est décédé et
sa fille qui souffre a les mêmes partis
manifester on fait peut-être les choses
pas complètement bien où on est prêt en
temps dans les prêts à changer quand a
commencé dans l'émission ne savais pas
que ça allait marcher ou pas tu as tu
fait pour que ça fonctionne c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on va essayer de faire
on va marcher dans ce sens là mais en
tout cas il ya des gens qui se battent
pour vous
si c'est vrai c'est mon analyse on s'est
même temps doit on fait des vrais dire
alors on fait peut-être pas tous bien je
peux pas dire je suis pas d'accord ils
vous je suis d'accord qu'avec nous pas
ceux ci ont tout est discutable tout on
fait pas tout bien mais en tout cas on
se bat psaume amoros c'est pas pour la
france
et là on a compris une chose maintenant
n'est plus divisé les français quand on
se retrouve dehors n'y a pas de noirs
n'y a pas de blague car ça ne commençait
pas quoi on se prend c'est vrai qu'il ya
une solidarité une facette du cpj jaune
c'est une famille c'est vrai je les ai
vus et si vous venez nous rejoindre
n'hésitez pas alors il ya pas de souci
merci dire merci dire merci jean claude
merci maxi merci averti je fais juste je
voudrais dire merci d'avoir été là on a
compris votre message
je vous dis je dis juste un dernier un
dernier truc la destitution du président
je vous dis là on peut hausser ses
lacets
c'est inimaginable donc on est chez non
mais non mais ce panneau est juste on
est chez nancy on est sympa mais on
essaie sauver une solution et on espère
qu'il y aura des solutions sont dès
samedi
vous le savez je sais que vous
travaillez pour tous les français et ce
que vous faites c'est pour que la vie
des français soit meilleur voilà au
quotidien mais essayer de travailler
avec les voiles avec les autorités et on
essaie de trouver des solutions parce
que c'est comme ça que ça va avancer et
nous on a juste envie d'un truc c'est
que vous soyez tous heureux et vous
pouviez plus y aller dormir parce que
vous n'avez pas dormi depuis plusieurs
jours et je sais que même les mecs voilà
je pense fort à vous parce que tout ça
et vous faites un truc de ouf